[Music]
in sarcastic apology news I'm sorry I'm
sorry you feel that way but those
submitted by wangster [ __ ] the TV show
South Park has been completely banned in
China after a recent episode true yeah
true
but you know why the gang get the China
walk episodes my glorious [ __ ] on the
mongolian know that Chinese yeah I
wonder if they got the jokes if when
it's translated yeah that's true cuz I
I've seen the Simpsons done in French
and and french-canadian and it is
completely different to the point where
the joke is so it was this trending
thing on Twitter I don't know it's not
by myself you speak French no I used to
my the rest of my family does okay do
you guys know about what the NBA did
with China I just I just heard about it
but please tell us
so the this isn't in the art world I'm
just gonna sum everything up so the
owner are not the owner the manager of
the Houston Rockets tweeted out in
support of Hong Kong and he was
immediately admonished by the NBA and
the NBA basically pressured him into
deleting the tweet and then apologizing
for Angelina and then Nike pulled
something and then Nike as well pulled a
Nike as well their sponsorship on on the
team on that Dominic Houston Rockets
yeah smart move on Mikey because they're
like we still want to make money all
right that's what all of our factories
in China we can't make command at
Cambodia and all and the Rockets
accounted for like 10 percent of all the
sales in China for NBA
yeah pretty good because of Yami yeah
right
like just he's on the team for just a
few years and that just [ __ ]
basketballs so famous in China huh and
then Jeremy Lin with Brooklyn exactly so
right so so so and the NBA is trying to
move into China and they want the
Chinese market place for like so then
South Park had coincidentally made this
episode because normally they have they
do that five days everything yeah where
they can make they can make a show very
very very quickly didn't we but this
episode was already apparently always
already done they weren't even trying to
make fun of the NBA and all that [ __ ]
but it was because of the Winnie the
Pooh thing yes because of the because
the they made it's been in 2017 when the
Pooh got banned in China because people
were making fun of Jim Payne saying that
he looks like Winnie the Pooh does he
does he know we're bad he looks oh I
feel like all Asian uncle's that are
kind of chubby look like we need the
pool and round face dish so now you get
the heard that it was a cute reference
to that someone said it and then it
became this big meme and then like I
loved that it was like yeah do you guys
know about what's wrong Hong Kong yes
yes protest right so the Hong Kong is
wants to have autonomy from China and
all that comes you okay so this episode
of South Park came out called banned in
China and they poke fun at China's
strict censorship laws and they
basically rip Hollywood a new [ __ ]
because Hollywood is trying to cater all
of their [ __ ] towards yeah they're
pandering to China because that's where
the money's at that's what people don't
know they just well they know but
they're put people a lot of people in
America are going well where are our
values then if we don't [ __ ] stand up
to the oppression that we all fought we
kind of that kind of mentality right
yeah like for example a Top Gun movie is
coming out it's the sequel to Top Gun
and they changed the the flag on the
back of his jacket because it used to be
about the war and now they scrub
Japanese or whatever it was a it was it
was the
okay never mind it doesn't matter the
point is is that China didn't want the
flag on the back of Tom Cruise's jacket
off so they took it off they changed it
what that's how much power they have see
how powerful yeah so Hollywood can't
wait to figure out how they can
configure things to make it work in the
Chinese market place because it's so
[ __ ] big well I also heard too that
the reason why is because the censorship
not only that but they only let X amount
of foreign movies in every year and they
want to dominate their own market and
the movie industry there is controlled
by the government so when they have like
national like releases of certain movies
or whatever then then they can kind of
guarantee the success of certain movies
because it'll be the only movie that
plays during release week that's a good
adhere to their guidelines right like it
can't be anything supernatural in it
because they don't like that that
they're trying to magic right the part
that's scary to me is so we're in our
country value freedom of speech so much
right and we fight all these like
quote-unquote oppressors and make sure
that there's democracy all over the
world but then with China we're not even
fighting a war but because they're so
financially powerful and all of us want
to do business over there that they can
slowly seep their ways in and I feel
like there could be a component in time
where we lose our freedom of speech like
not my law but by practice no doubt well
cuz of all these private corporations if
they're gonna pander over to that side
it's already happening right now so
that's what happened right our
politicians are sold out like our
country to the Chinese in many ways and
that is seeping into culture now where
Hollywood selling out to China and
sports in like every category boom boom
buy these [ __ ] culture is being sold
to China because money works right so in
the past it was all about like politics
and the Cold War and then who's who's
like ideals are gonna win now it's like
they figured it out they're like well
you guys will do anything for money
right and money will win so you guys
could be sitting here talking about
cultural values and all this stuff and
you I'm gonna just come in with a lot of
money and all of your companies will
[ __ ] play - my favorite yeah just like
a corporate takeover yeah and that's
kind of what a lot of people are
complaining about soul who pushes back
as always my [ __ ] heroes for your
Parker bad Stone South Park
they have an episode called banned in
China and they basically well I just
said that but yeah so I'm repeating
myself because I didn't smoke now which
is something that TIFF does is a
seasoned professional and that I do not
do very much okay so what's awesome is
that you know what else is pretty
professional complete subscribing to
this channel yes they should they should
subscribe because on JK news we we don't
back down but we never talk [ __ ] about
China no because we love Charlie [ __ ]
love China we love it so much you love
tangle I love MSG yeah oh yeah it's good
and I personally love China so much to
the point well I will never say [ __ ]
China no I would never say that because
it's just I would even think of saying
[ __ ] China in the ass I would never
write and I wouldn't think about Xi
Jinping getting [ __ ] in the ass by
anything so much [ __ ] the Communist
Party because that's never on my
thoughts saying I'm all about like you
know I believe that we should all censor
each other and I would never say like go
Falun Gong you guys raw [ __ ] China I
would never I would never say anything
like I would endorse that statement
thank you
so what's what happened as a result of
South Park doing this episode where they
[ __ ] all over China is Beijing delete
deleted all South Park clips everything
because they have control over their
like they hit the button and you're
deleted okay so what happens if your
trap have you gone back I'm not only
from China but my foot my I have family
there so if you go back and look like
when I travel abroad I use my phone and
I just like pay for the data every day
when you travel to China are you under
there internet laws yeah you are I mean
I wouldn't know cuz I go to Taiwan then
how are all these journalists getting
the videos and everything over to me
that was on Instagram and Facebook when
I was in China so you can use it it's
it's different for the citizens of China
how how is it how do they regulate who's
on the wavelength they they have strict
controls over their people and Jenna I
mean I believe it though because our
buddies they run some dance studios out
there and then there was a there was a
time when they banned hip-hop and it got
to the point where there they were
luring out piercing fungi so they were
basically they blurred out there they
have the power to blur out or bad a
whole entire culture overnight because
once that went into play they were going
to do this like dance special on TV and
they had the government officials came
in and they looked and in they were
watching their dad's move and they're
like take that out take this everything
that's to hip-hop culture take that song
change it whatever
yeah you said immediately like within
hours of that happening like a whole
team came into their hotel room was like
you got a you got a change in all this
choreography with the hip gyration we
got to take all that out so ever get the
change overnight so there's obviously a
black market in China for a lot of [ __ ]
right because why control so there's got
there's some ones out there like they
have they have oh we need the Pooh movie
or something and inter-pass an action
around you know yeah yeah probably
anything underneath the shirt isn't
blurred out yeah right so so South Park
came out and and basically issued a
response and they said via Twitter Trey
Parker Matt Stone said like the NBA
we welcome the Chinese censors into our
homes and our hearts me to love money
more than freedom and democracy
Sheeta she doesn't like look she doesn't
look like Winnie the Pooh at all Xi
Jinping yeah the statement continued
long live the great Communist Party of
China made this autumns sorghum's
hardest be Bal Harvest be bountiful we
good not China we good help oh my god I
love them so much
autumns sorghum harvest be bountiful Oh
we're game is like it's like if when you
fry it a kind of bursts up like popcorn
but it doesn't have that weird mouth
feel like when you bite down on popcorn
it sticks to your teeth
it's a lot airier so it's a food yeah I
think so cuz it's a harvest that's what
the part that I got same huh I'm with
you yes so so um and then another thing
that they just did to treat the
reference to the Communist Party being
like Farmers Union kind of world so it's
like may your harvest be bountiful work
will set you free
yes that kind of saw CNN reporter was
just at an NBA press conference and they
were asking a player about
China and they had their microphone
taken away from them I didn't see this
video though I heard it just happen
today I know I haven't seen it yet video
but I don't have it here cuz gonna say
something they just snatched it he said
some things and then and then she said
it looks pretty relevant thing that's
going on right now and they snatched the
microphone they were kids at the 70 the
people who were working over us because
there's that's what I'm saying yeah
there are kids at the 76 sirs game
holding up free Hong Kong signs and it
got kicked out no it was on the news
that I gathered that though from yeah it
was the 76ers number people say Sixers
but yeah what is it then it is the 76ers
but no one went 76ers it's just the
sixth it's like the Dodgers they just
saved jersey people say Niners
instead of the Rams they just say that
beautiful second you made me feel like I
was walking around talking like a noob
any time I mentioned the Dodgers yep Wow
it's pretty crazy so there's this
Chinese billionaire that was that he he
what do you call it
not refugee status but asylum because
I'm seeking asylum here in the u.s. he's
a [ __ ] billionaire right he moved all
of his money ran over here and since
like the mid-90s or some [ __ ] like that
he's been saying watch out America watch
out for [ __ ] China because you're
doing all these damn deals you're doing
all this stuff and you don't even know
that they're [ __ ] they have us by the
balls and he and now like he was he
first started like everyone was like
calling him this crazy guy but now
people are starting to listen to him and
he also had his own like YouTube channel
and every day he's just like trying to
shell out propaganda of like what's not
propaganda but he's trying to call out
the conspiracy of what China is doing
and now he's actually getting meetings
with people cuz he's like she's like now
I've been saying this for 20 years you
guys weren't [ __ ] listening to me but
they have this greater good plan the
greater good plan is of course China
number one and then so what that means
is they'll step on their own people
they'll step on other countries they
don't give a [ __ ] because it's all about
being number one for the greater good of
all of trying to kill 60 million of
their own people they don't care
yeah why because they're protesters
they're against the government all kinds
of differences yeah yeah they've got the
people to spare though mm-hmm Tennessee
for billions they have a lot of people
that's a lot sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]